I just got a message about this great
project.
This device would help millions of people in the rehabilitation process.
Consumers saving money and investors earning.
But there's a problem.
Ideas need opportunities and investors to make them happen.
So how can we help?
Come, follow me!
This is the EU investment portal. It works like an online
speed-dating platform for EU projects
and investors worldwide; and finds the
perfect match.
What is really great about it: it's free easy-to-use, safe
one-stop shop with no middleman
It's not only for big projects even small ones can apply.
I just found a match.
There's a potential investor.
So, are you an investor or a project promoter?
Do you want to try?  Then, all you have to do is register.
The next success story may be yours.